ha sido catalogado como el naufragio más
mortífero en lo que va del año las
autoridades de Grecia informaron sobre
el hundimiento de un barco pesquero en
el marjónico se cree que entre 400 y 750
personas de distintas nacionalidades
iban a bordo
de hecho es una situación Trágica una
situación muy difícil con una gran
cantidad de náufragos una cantidad que
creo que no hemos enfrentado en el
pasado en tal medida ni volumen
según medios griegos la guardia costera
de ese país detectó la embarcación y
ofreció ayuda pero sus tripulantes la
rechazaron unas horas más tarde se volcó
y se hundió al parecer casi todos los
ocupantes eran hombres jóvenes alrededor
de los 20 años la mayoría provenientes
de Egipto Siria y Pakistán
la embarcación partió desde la ciudad
Libia de tobruck y tenía como Destino
final Italia pero se accidentó a unos
kilómetros de la ciudad costera de pilos
al sur de Grecia hasta allí fueron
trasladados los sobrevivientes Quienes
fueron repartidos entre hospitales y
refugios
la presidenta de Grecia hizo presencia
en la zona y la ONU se refirió a lo
ocurrido
la única forma en que obtendremos
caminos seguros la única forma en que
evitaremos que las personas emprendan
estos viajes peligrosos la única forma
en que Sacaremos a las bandas criminales
de esta ecuación es si solo los países
de origen los países de tránsito y los
países de destino trabajan juntos Grecia
es una de las principales rutas de
entrada a la Unión Europea para
migrantes y refugiados creando un
mercado ilegal que cada vez es más
grande y difícil de controlar